Darauf wartet die Astronomie seit Jahrzehnten.
Sie sucht einen Exoplaneten, der nicht nur
in der habitablen, also der bewohnbaren Zone,
rund um sein Zentralgestirn kreist, sondern
auch Wasser enthält.
Das Warten hat ein Ende.
Hubble hat ihn entdeckt.
Und es gab eine Überraschung.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Das mit der habitablen Zone ist so eine Sache.
Es ist eine Vermutung, aber sie könnte auch
nicht so ganz stimmen.
Wenn der Saturnmond Enceladus zum Beispiel
Leben beherbergen würde, dann wäre das der
Beweis, dass es gar keine habitable Zone braucht,
lediglich Rahmenbedingungen, die Leben ermöglichen.
Bei Enceladus wären das heiße Quellen und
der Saturn mit seiner Gravitation, der den
Mond so durchknetet, dass Wasser trotz Temperaturen
unter dem Gefrierpunkt dort flüssig bleibt.
Aber generell gilt nur in der habitablen Zone
entstehen solche Bedingungen gesetzmäßig.
Wasser ist dort flüssig und Leben kann entstehen
und sich entwickeln.
Wasser gilt weiterhin neben Sauerstoff als
zentrale Element, um Leben zu ermöglichen
und es enthält Sauerstoff.
Je nach Stern und abhängig von seiner Aktivität
kann diese Zone groß, klein, nah oder entfernt
vom Zentralgestirn sein.
Je nach Stern kann sie also ganz anders ausgeprägt
sein.
Doch eines bleibt dort immer gleich.
Es ist dort so kalt, dass Wasser nicht verdampft
und so warm, dass es nicht gefriert.
Wenn also ein Planet in der habitablen Zone
liegt und seine Atmosphäre Wasser enthält
ist es nach jetzigem Wissensstand wahrscheinlich,
dass dort auch Leben existieren kann.
Jetzt hat das Weltraumteleskop Hubble zum
ersten Mal genau einen solchen Exoplaneten
entdeckt.
Wobei der Planet ist schon länger bekannt,
seit 2015.
Damals wurde er vom Keppler Weltraumteleskop
entdeckt, dass auf die Entdeckung von Exoplaneten
spezialisiert ist.
Quadrant für Quadrant sucht es nach ihnen
den Himmel ab.
Dabei untersucht das Weltraumteleskop, ob
sich Sterne periodisch verdunkeln.
Passiert das regelmäßig, dann wurde ein
Exoplaneten entdeckt.
Das ist das sogenannte Transitverfahren.
K2-18b kreist rund 110 Lichtjahre von uns
entfernt um einen Stern, ist in astronomischen
Maßstäben also relativ nah.
Er ist rund achtmal so schwer wie die Erde,
aber kleiner als der Uranus und gilt damit
als sogenannte Supererde.
Nur wegen der geringen Entfernung konnte Hubble
jetzt die Atmosphäre von K2-18b untersuchen.
Denn eigentlich ist Hubble für solche Aufgaben
viel zu schwach.
Das James Webb-Weltraumsteleskop soll das
ab 2021 mit einer hundertfach besseren Auflösung
als das Hubbleteleskop ermöglichen.
Wow.
Deshalb ist es extrem aussergewöhnlich, dass
es jetzt schon mit dem Hubble Teleskop gelungen
ist.
Dabei hat das Teleskop das Sternenspektrum
in dem Moment untersucht, in dem K2-18b vor
deinem Stern K2-18 vorbeizieht.
Dann strahlt das Licht nämlich durch seine
Atmosphäre und verändert es.
Bestimmte Lichtanteile werden durch die Atmosphäre
des Exoplaneten geschickt.
Dadurch weiß man relativ genau, was in der
Atmosphäre enthalten ist.
Bei K2-18b sind es Wasserdampf, Wasserstoff
und Helium.
Bam.
Ich weiß, dass ich es oft sage, aber in der
Astronomie ist nun mal jede Entdeckung eine
Entdeckung und bedeutet eine Erkenntnis, die
es so vorher nicht gab.
Das hier ist eine absolute Sensation.
Der erste Exoplanet mit lebensfreundlichen
Bedingungen.
Aber: Zwei Einschränkungen: Es wurde keine
Spuren in der Atmosphäre gefunden, die auf
Leben schliessen lassen, also kein Methan
und der Stern K2-18 ist so aktiv, dass der
Planet wahrscheinlich durch so viel Strahlung
getroffen wird, dass Leben dort nicht entstehen
kann.
Aber noch ein Aber: "Wasser auf einer potenziell
bewohnbaren Welt jenseits der Erde zu finden,
ist unfassbar aufregend", das sagt Angelos
Tsiaras vom University College in London.
Er ist Mitautor der Studie.
Er und sein Kollege Ingo Waldmann vermuten
aufgrund der Größe des Planeten und der
Zusammensetzung der Atmosphäre keine zweite
Erde mit wirklich lebensfreundlichen Bedingungen.
Und noch ein Aber: "Dennoch bringt uns die
Entdeckung einer Antwort auf die grundlegende
Frage näher: Ist die Erde einzigartig?“
sagt Zsiras.
Tja, seit der Entdeckung von Wasser auf K2-18b
ist es die Erde nicht mehr so ganz.
Und diese Entdeckung bedeutet, dass schon
in naher Zukunft mehr Exoplaneten mit Wasser
entdeckt werden dürften, auf jeden Fall mit
dem James Webb-Weltraumteleskop ab 2021.
Und dann steigen die Chancen exponential,
dass wir einen Erdzwilling vielleicht sogar
mit nachweisbarem Leben entdecken.
Wow!
Warum wir noch keine Aliens gefunden haben?
Das erklärt Marius mit Gong Bao hier: Anklicken,
Anschauen und den Hammerkanal abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!